parmi les crimes les plus traumatisants
subies par les agriculteurs figurent le
vol d'animaux et pour élucider ces
crimes on se tourne de plus en plus par
les réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
c'est des choses des biens mais c'est
des animaux tes amours
ça représente 5000 pièces de revenus par
année puis c'est des bails que j'ai
élevé
Guillaume la chaîne élève des bovins de
boucherie à Ferme-Neuve dans les Hautes
Laurentides dans la nuit du 18 septembre
2018 il se fait voler 11 vaches et 12
volts les animaux étaient dans un
pâturage à 4 km de sa résidence
contrairement aux vaches laitières ces
animaux vivent à l'extérieur à temps
plein
c'est pas évident à faire
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de caméra de surveillance
près du pâturage l'enquête s'annonce
difficile l'éleveur fait appel aux
réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
dans quel secteur rendu itinéraire du
camion tout le monde m'avait commenté on
avait un camion tout à l'heure tout à
l'heure
on savait tout le trajet jusqu'à
mon transporteur est arrivée rouge en
près de débarquer des agneaux c'est un
producteurs
selon les témoignages recueillis les
animaux auraient pris la direction de
l'Ontario ce qui est important que les
animaux c'est parce que il y a pas de
numéro de série là-dessus
de la Police provinciale de l'Ontario
qui prend l'enquête en main première
cible l'entente d'animaux de Vannes non
loin de la frontière du Québec un témoin
rapporte la présence d'animaux qui ne
sont pas identifiés à l'un des puces
habituellement accrochés aux oreilles
des bovins les trois veaux sont
immédiatement saisis ce sont ceux de
Guillaume lachane l'éleveur annonce la
nouvelle il explique qu'il n'est pas
assuré adéquatement pour la perte de ses
bêtes de là son acharnement aller
retrouver
deux mois plus tard la majorité des
bovins sont retrouvés abandonnés dans un
champ au bord de l'autoroute 417 tout
près du site de l'encan de Vannes click
Hill j'ai été envoyé un appel d'un
animal sur le bord de sur votre 417
quand je suis arrivé là la vache est en
train de manger le gazon à travers de la
neige les vaches avaient l'air maigre
puis il y avait la moitié du troupeau
qui mangeait les restants de feuilles
c'est ces armes qui restaient il
manquait deux temps que dans une oreille
puis une table dans l'autre oreille ce
qui m'a encore donne fait penser que
c'est des vaches du Québec en plus
d'être policier
[Musique]
chaîne a été un indice important
je sais que des fois quand on va lâcher
certains sons les troupeaux ils sont
habitués à nous puis ils vont se diriger
vers nous quand j'ai pu dire à 100% que
c'était les vaches à Monsieur daching
un moment donné je me suis la chaîne il
y a lâché 3 400 puis c'était de voir les
vaches sortir du champ cabin
l'impression en famille comme Keita qui
était content de le voir j'ai eu de
comme un genre de chair de poule de voir
avec les vaches à retrouver d'un maître
très content pour ces animaux-là il y
avait vraiment besoin d'avoir des soins
un peu meilleur que qu'est-ce qu'il y
avait il y avait perdu au moins 150 à
200 livres puis il y en a une qui avait
perdu 300 livres je me disais les
méchants cabochons c'est voler des
animaux pour les faire souffrir c'est ça
fait pas partie des valeurs des
producteurs c'est pas demain qu'on élève
nos bêtes là ça c'est des cabochons qui
font ça
dans les jours qui suivent deux suspects
sont arrêtés ils seront condamnés pour
vol depuis les détails de leur modus
operanzi ont filtré ça faisait une coupe
de semaine qui avait quelqu'un le soir
qui allait porter de la mouleuse
de partir trois camions avec les
remorques rentrée des champs ce qui
était des animaux collé les remorques là
le mot où ils ont raffermé d'un clôture
puis on chargé un voyage et on passe
c’était facile puis on passe qu'il
devait voler ça impositeur
depuis monsieur lachain a changé
l'emplacement de son pâturage et la
rapprocher de sa ferme il a aussi acheté
des caméras de surveillance de sa
mésaventure il a choisi de retenir le
positif sa collaboration avec la police
provinciale de l'Ontario
[Musique]
[Rires]
difficile d'avoir un portrait d'ensemble
du vol d'animaux puisque l'indemnisation
des pertes liées à ce type de crime
relève des assurances privées
on sait toutefois que dans l'ouest du
pays le vol de bétail est suffisamment
courant pour que la GRC est une unité
d'enquête spécialement dédiée à ce type
de crime en Alberta et en
Colombie-Britannique
au Québec rien de tout cela ici le vol
le plus spectaculaire à ce jour en
agriculture est-ce que l'on a surnommé
le vol de sirop d'érable du siècle en
2011 3000 tonnes du précieux liquide ont
été subtilisés de la réserve stratégique
de sirop d'érable de Laurierville
dans la province les vols constituent
moins de 4% des réclamations en
assurance agricole et ce sont surtout
des vols de machineries qui sont
rapportés chez nos voisins français ce
sont les vols de moutons qui ont fait la
manchette ces dernières années les
éleveurs ont manifesté sur la place
publique de Nantes en Loire pour
sensibiliser la population à ce fléau
ces capteurs là ils sont suivis en temps
réel sur un logiciel d'une application
toujours en France des apiculteurs ont
installé des GPS sur certaines de leurs
ruches pour contrer le vol d'abeille
comme des petits GPS à mettre dans les
abeilles avec
une compagnie de sécurité puis il était
je pense que il y a quelque chose de
sortie là-dessus on tenterait de
regarder ça mais je pense que notamment
à fait que je n'arrête pas à d'autres
voleurs
[Musique]
c'était en 2016 au printemps une journée
comme celle-ci dans les champs de Saint
Valère dans le centre du Québec français
c'est Mathieu Labonté préparer leur
ruche pour les louer à des producteurs
de petits fruits les abeilles
pollinisent leur production c'était un
mardi après-midi 4h 4h30 je faisais une
tournée parce qu'il y avait eu des
grands vins pour voir s'il y avait rien
déranger dans mes rucher
ma réaction
et ça se pouvait simplement voir
le site
qui ont d'abbeille voler chez l'un des
apiculteurs les plus connus du Québec
24 heures sur 24
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup de fatigue parce que on
allait chercher on avait des appels que
ça arrête on voulait trouver
la famille remue si elle était location
d'hélicoptère battue dans la région les
caméras de sécurité du pont la violette
livre finalement les premiers indices
chez moi
de vérifier sur le pont de Tourville les
Cameroun on va savoir c'est quel bon
chercher le Club 55
les soupçons pointent rapidement vers
des individus qui gravitent dans
l'entourage d'une apicultrice l'hiver
avait été difficile pour ses abeilles et
les suspects auraient voulu reconstituer
la ruche à peu de frais
c'est quelqu'un qui connaît les ruche
qui a à faire là c'est pas c'est pas
quelqu'un qui
pense la publicité qui va aller voler
des ruches
on ne subit assez bien équipé
[Musique]
percussion a eu lieu où on a trouvé une
remorque et à l'intérieur de la remorque
on a trouvé des éléments en fait des
morceaux qui peuvent s'apparenter à des
qui pouvaient provenir des ruches
un premier suspect a été arrêté
oui l'homme de Mandeville dans la
naudière fait face à deux chefs
d'accusation d'abord vol de plus de 5000
dollars et également possession de
matériel volés
procès accusé
les frères la montée on sécurisé le
remplacement
ils ont perdu 100000 dollars dans
l'aventure et la paix d'esprit
de ça mais on était rouvre une crainte
d'arriver une place qui manque des
ruches mais ça reste marqué quand même
pas de dormir
c'est un très court
qui reste